I'm Jackie Collins and my favorite movie
is the Godfather
the Godfather is one of the classic
movies of all time I was in London and I
was seeing The Godfather for the first
time and I was on a date with some
moronic guy and I couldn't wait to get
rid of him
and go back the next day and see the
film again so I could concentrate on it
you see the characters they come to life
on the screen and the actors at the time
was so dynamic and and charismatic I
just thought it was a fantastic movie
and it gave me the inspiration to write
my first book about the Santangelo
family and that was about the gangster
with a heart of gold
and one reviewer in London when they
were reviewing my book said are it's the
Godfather goes to bed it's not personal
it's strictly business you know there's
so many great lines in The Godfather but
that's why you have to see it again
in a game because every time you see it
there's something different take the gun
leave the cannoli I mean who can make up
a line like that well I could I like to
think I could but you know it gives you
inspiration that you can do anything you
can say anything I tried to write my
books like people speak you know and
that's what they did in the Godfather
was the way people spoke you know food
was a good part of their life
relationships and then of course the
dynamic of family and I tried to take an
inspiration from that which I did but
I'm not going to write women who sit
around waiting for some man so they gave
me that thought that women should be
stronger and when I created the
character of Gino's Santangelo I then
created lucky his daughter and lucky was
a really strong woman she can do
anything she wants to do and that's what
I think women should be able to do today
on the screen and off the screen so I do
inspire women to pick themselves up
because I think women should follow
their dream I mean I'm a school dropout
I've been in 32 books and I followed my
dream nobody encouraged me nobody gave
me any help I just said this is what I
want to do and
I'm gonna do it I'm Jackie Collins and I
love movies